that night in October a neighbor saw
Nikki near the block of flats at ten
past nine
around five minutes later another
witness spotted her outside this Pub
wearing the clothes on which police
decades later would find David Boyd's
DNA
around 30 minutes later another witness
saw a man followed by a young girl
the prosecution said the police sketch
matches how David Boyd looked at the
time security camera footage was the
last sighting
a grainy video that the prosecution
claimed showed David Boyd with Nikki
behind him skipping to her death
the next day around 9 A.M neighbors
found Nikki's coat shoes and later her
body in the basement of this abandoned
building